das lose ja nicht auch wieder verlieren
ist sehr cool is cool aber es hat einen
riesen vorteil die nieten sind
gekennzeichnet das sind hier diese roten
oder rosa rose die grünen sind die
gewinner lohse das sind auch fragen die
roten sind unverschämt die grünen sind
harmlos ach komm ich werde jetzt
sicherlich jeder wir enttäuscht gewesen
wie eine grüne gezogen
hätten allerdings rechts ab ich lese ich
natürlich vor ja ja genau genau
wie auf der kirmes google
patientin sie meinen selbst dass sie so
ziemlich alle drogen genommen die es
gibt haben die keinen bleibenden schaden
hinterlassen
ich meine wir haben da jetzt eine stunde
miteinander geredet die frage ich glaube
die vollkommen überflüssig oder
was man sich noch dazu sagen möchte ist
man kann raketen auf den mond schießen
man kann mittlerweile den auch mit
kameras auf den mars fahren und unsere
foto schießen aber irgendwie droge zu
entwickeln die uns erstens nicht kaputt
macht die uns irgendwie dabei hilft das
leben zu optimieren was ja
wahrscheinlich auch nötig ist dazu sind
wir nicht in der lage und das irgendwie
blöd also eine gute droge weltklasse
wenn gute droge wer klasse eine droge
die an die schon gesagt ein nicht sozial
ins abseits stelle die einigen die
finanziell nicht kaputtmacht die
anerkannt ist und die einfach ein
bisschen dabei hilft
fluffig zu sein für die leute die es
nötig zu sein es gibt eine menge leute
die es können zwar aus dem bauch heraus
das wäre schon sinnvoll oder täusch ich
mich da kann mir gut vorstellen aber das
scheint ja auch ein bisschen natur zu
sein
das ist natürlich schrecklich und ich
muss natürlich auch dazu sagen weil es
steht irgendwie alle drogen die es gibt
es gibt natürlich auch die gewisse
bücher die natürlich auch immer gewisse
stämme und im galopp indianer oder
sonstwas im urwald da gibt es auch schon
wirklich leute schamanen und solche
geschichten die habe ich natürlich nicht
ausprobieren dürfen definiert finde ich
immer noch sehr sehr spannend wenn man
dann plötzlich irgendwie mit
irgendwelchen ahnen und damit gegen
welchen anderen dimensionen in kontakt
tritt wenn irgendwelche als liegt darum
geht irgendwie am samstagabend klasse
drauf zu sein oder so wenn es wirklich
zum kultur spiegel gehört seit langem
lagerzeit zum kultur
zum kulturerbe und auch nur gewisse
leute tun dürfen die einer gewissen
position in den sind richtig richtig
spannend und da finde ich drogen auch
irgendwie fast schon mystisch und
sinnvoll wir haben noch mehr langsam
mehren sind alle speziell für dich
überlegt kennen wir natürlich nur eine
rote und gleich eine grüne
weil ihrer karriere musste da ein
werbespot wirklich sein also erstens
muss ich sagen das ist das ist das
karriere ein wort ist mit dem ich
wirklich nicht so besonders gut umgehen
kann weil bei uns in der schauspielerei
ist dieses up and down wirklich
atemberaubend ich bin mittlerweile 48
jahre alt ich habe im grunde fast
anderthalb familien zu wuppen und es ist
wirklich nicht ab nicht spannend und
aufregend wenn man wirklich von woche zu
woche man einmal von monat zu monat und
manchmal von woche zu woche nicht weiter
gehen soll das ist nicht besonders
amüsant und dann muss ich zugeben habe
ich diesen werbespot vorher lesen können
und war irgendwie vom instinkt er ist
mein instinkt angesprungen sagte deiss
was und ich hab mich nicht getäuscht es
ist irgendwie ein werbespot geworden der
wirklich
außergewöhnlich geworden ist und der
meiner karriere sogar ein gewissen
anschub gegeben hat ja ja ja ich habe
also eine lange zeit versucht seriöses
zelluloid zu machen und durch meine
qualitative arbeit für den leuten ins
bewusstsein zu rücken hat mich da auch
sehr bemüht und dann kommt mir so einen
zehn sekunden dingen über den weg
gelaufen und innerhalb kürzester zeit
kannte mich beziehungsweise mal gesicht
jeder es ist nicht so einfach wenn leute
sagen ich kenne sie ihnen woher woher
denn und du hast keine feste serie dass
wir sagen ganz naja sie können nicht von
18 25 soko leipzig oder so jetzt kann
ich immer sagen wie änderte sich an der
wsws von achter sind sie alles klar also
kann ich mir manche großen gespräch auf
der straße und manche peinlichen
desorientierung weil ich weiß nicht was
die leute gucken wo die mich letztens
gesehen haben könnte nicht genauso gut
beim
gassi gehen und mein mund ja wenn ich an
hätte gesehen haben das ist immer
schwierig über eine halbe stunde mit
leuten die man nicht kennt steht und
raus versucht rauszukriegen woher die
einen kennen das ist eine sind mit
miriam pielhau besprochen manchmal ist
es ja so dass sie andenken dass die
denken sie würden ein wirklich privat
kennen
wie geht es dir denn wir haben diesen
effekt dadurch dass du dir dass du im
fernsehen das werden die auf der couch
sitzen das dass du neben denen sie ist
dass du die nicht sie ist das ist
manchmal gar nicht so richtig bewusst
nennen aber deswegen habe ich mich
trotzdem höflicher mensch und freue mich
dann dass sie diesen diesen diesen
diesen joker jetzt der tasche aber sagen
so gut sie kann mit ihren werbespot lws
und dann sind sie auch zufrieden aber
wenn du ihnen keine antwort geben ganz
können die wirklich hartnäckig sein und
dann wird man auch unangenehm da würde
ich wirklich nicht mehr gehen lassen
während du irgendwie zur post muss oder
so du hast ja auch ein leben alltag da
kannst du bist du schon mal geneigt zu
sagen herr gott ich weiß nicht woher die
mich kennen und deswegen ist es mit dem
lwl sport schon ganz gut die grünen
begrüßen klar
das ist toll das klang vor allem mit den
ländern wir so zurück an diese
geschichte mit dem wir so gerne auf
klimas gewesen sie wurden von der
schauspielschule abgelehnt woher wussten
sie trotzdem dass sie das talent zum
schauspieler haben
das liegt lag eigentlich daran dass ich
dass ich als ich angefangen habe die
schauspielerei zu entdecken es ging
eigentlich los durch so eine
schul-ag arbeitsgemeinschaft wo man wo
der lehrer dann sagt hören kannst das
und nicht mich plötzlich irgendwie auch
wohl fühlte mit einer aufgabe hat hier
früher an die nur mein fußball er hat ja
nicht was ich gut konnte und wo ich mich
sicher gefühlt habe und dann dachte ich
eigentlich was sie schon immer
schauspieler und schauspieler ist alles
anderes als klassenclown der ja
eigentlich immer gewesen bin ich war nie
besonders starker typ das heißt wenn ich
ein patrouille geraten wenn es zu
schlägereien oder so ging war ich
entweder mit dem maul vorne und konnte
mich irgendwie rausreden
das sind eigentlich alles qualitäten die
ich früher schon hatte den schauspieler
am ende seiner karriere auch hat der
clown zu sein und sich nicht allen
möglichen situationen durch
schauspielerisches talent rausreden zu
können also bin ich im union befinden
wie schauspieler gewesen
und er war noch eine oder sehr gerne in
lieber noch eine rote sind irgendwie
anders
sie bewerben sich für den beruf des
polizisten des tierpräparator sind auf
der schauspielschule und würden überall
abgelehnt hatten die nicht gute gründe
also die also die polizisten die ihr
präparatoren da war noch die aral also
die die forschung eines großen
mineralölkonzerns dabei und so die
hatten schon gute gründe weil das hört
sich jetzt vielleicht an wie was jeder
sagt aber ich war ein absoluter
eine absolute mathematik miete jetzt
wird natürlich jeder seiner bin ich auch
bin ich auch war ich auch aber bei mir
wirklich das treffen
man hätte mich fragen können eine ampel
hat rot gelb und grün als farbe wie
viele was ergeht es als summe die wir
auch drei nicht gekommen deswegen war
ich glaube jede prüfung eigentlich
bestanden bis auf mathematik da würde
ich kann keinen 3 satz ich hab
verweigere mich komplett dieser
naturwissenschaft obwohl ich sie höchst
faszinierend finde
deswegen haben sie gute gründe die
schauspielschule hatte deswegen
vielleicht einen guten grund weil ich
mich nicht klassisch vorbereitete
sondern ich hab diesen monolog von
robert de niro und textil du bist tot du
willst nicht [__] vorgesprochen und
das war vielleicht vom geschmack her ein
wenig zu kalt nicht machen ja das glaube
ich nicht aber sie waren wahrscheinlich
habe niemals mit sein oder nicht sein
weil sie fragt mich danach noch okay
da haben sie doch irgendwas anderes
vielleicht was klassisches vorbereitet
und da also danke das war schon
schwierig genug
weil er meine karriere schule beendet ok
eine grüne noch unseren lage nicht haben
doch jetzt gleich hier nicht
einigermaßen
sie haben eine exzessive vergangenheit
mit rüpeleien mit der polizei und so
ziemlich alle drogen die man sich vor
ort
das ist
die mit dem du ja ja ich aber nicht
infrage aber
wir haben schon viel früher war
früher waren sie punk musiker zauberer
zorniger theatermacher und jetzt drehen
sie mag filme und serien aus angst ihrer
familie nicht ernähren zu können ist aus
ihm ein sicherheitsfanatiker und spießer
geworden also
ich drehe also filme und serien
sicherlich nicht im akkord aber viel
aber viel ja auch noch niemand dass in
der er ist so dass das dass das ich mir
eigentlich schon t shirt anziehen wollte
auf dem draufsteht
produzenten und filmemacher
geht man kalt duschen weil sich schon so
dass ich manche leute die wirklich
insider sind die zu mir gesagt habe ich
gar nicht gebucht für drei vier tage
wollte wie so oft zu sehen aber diese
sachen die wir so oft zu sehen sind sind
erst schon abgedreht also das geld schon
ausgegeben
zweitens sind davon fast 90%
wiederholung so dass ich eigentlich
sagen muss nicht was ich als reines geld
verdiene ist wirklich nicht viel und
dadurch dass ich das ich dass ich wie es
hier stehen möglichst viele von diesen
sachen annehme die mir angeboten werden
ist es ist deswegen weil wir nicht nicht
nicht genug
im bereich des dass das der großen kunst
angeboten wird ich würde viel lieber so
eine geschichte wie die coups drehen
viel lieber irgendwie eins von diesen
historischen dramen die wir da momentan
oft gesehen haben wie die mauer und der
tunnel und alle diese geschichten aber
diese leute haben nicht irgendwie noch
nicht kommentieren und da ich in den
beruf des schauspielers halt arbeite
und aufarbeiten möchte
und ich nicht in der position mit mir
etwas aussuchen zu dürfen dass liegen
fünf sachen auf dem tisch wo ich sage da
war ich mir das beste aus sondern sie
nicht nur eins auf dem tisch und das ist
das einzige deswegen bleibt übrig so war
vielen dank ja ich mache